yo what's up everybody mad Luigi here
and I guess more fault for news for you
guys not too big but it's kind of cool
and i thought i would share with you
guys just in case you didn't hear that
so the embargo lifts date has been
revealed and by open critic calm and
it's going to be november nine at 5am
and other obviously we can ask other
sources it looks like it's going to be
november nineteenth s it looks like it's
confirmed to be that and so we're going
to have essentially an entire day of
fallout 4 reviews and content before the
game comes out so this is more for
people that haven't decided they want to
buy the game or not an hour art can be
playing at day one i know i'm going to
be playing day one and a good amount of
people are going to be playing day one
it is interesting information for us but
not as important as people who don't i
don't know if they want to get the game
these reviews will come in and people
will be able to decide through the
reviews what they want to do if they
want to get the game at the game sounds
good and also we can see for us that are
going to get the game on day one even
regardless of the reviews we can see
what people feel about it or maybe we
want to go in blind and we're not gonna
look at any of it personally i'm gonna
try and look at some reviews that are
essentially spoiler-free i'm gonna try
and find those and i'm going to see what
people are saying about the game so i
can have an idea of what to expect since
I don't think I'm going blind but I
don't want to know that much so that's
why I'm going to avoid spoilers and I
will be able to see more gameplay get a
better feel for the game before it comes
out which is always better to be more
prepared in my mind also because I'm a
content creator it is good to be better
prepared to show you guys information
about the game so other people that have
access to the information I can see it
from what they have since i don't have a
I don't have review copy to give that to
release I don't have any reviews to
release on the embargo since I don't
have to copy of the game since I'm a
pretty small contributor in terms of
content views and stuff but there has
been a ton of like unboxing and people
and press getting the game so you know
that people have it and they're playing
it you can see on the steam page the
people currently in fall of four
it's like the amount of players that are
in it and also there's just tons and
tons of unboxing videos of just the
pip-boy ditions or the normal editions
just a lot of that so we know people
have it and from all these sources we
know it's going to be released on
November night the embargo not the game
obviously in the game is still november
temp and so yeah that's kind of it for
the video is just a quick little update
that i want to let you guys know just in
case you didn't if you're really keeping
up and fall for news you probably
already know this and i apologize if i'm
repeating stuff you already know but
yeah the title of the video is embargoed
8 release something to do with that so
you should you should have an idea of
what coming into the video so I hope you
guys have enjoyed this if you are
looking for more fallout 4 content be
sure to check out my channel and keep
coming back since i will be posting a
lot of fallout 4 content i'm really
excited for this and i'm really excited
to post a lot of stuff about it since
it's gonna be swag alright so I hope you
guys enjoyed this quick little news
video I guess I don't know it wasn't
that much to it and yeah thanks for
watching peace out